[Musik]
seit tagen beherrschen genau solche
videos und bilder zum krieg in der
ukraine das internet vor allem natürlich
die sozialen netzwerke das sind zb
angeblich russische truppen am
atomkraftwerk in tschernobyl aber ist
das video authentisch
wir zeigen wie wir hier in der
nachrichtenredaktion genau solche videos
und fotos verifiziert und wie das auch
jeder zu hause am laptop selber machen
kann dieses video soll ja im
kernkraftwerk von tschernobyl
aufgenommen worden sein das praktische
ist diese ganze gegend die gibt es auch
bei google streetview ich muss also nur
dieses männchen hier auf die karte
ziehen und dann kann ich mich da vor ort
umschauen in diesem video sehen wir sehr
viele markante dinge wir sehen hier ein
gebäude wir sehen diese bögen wir sehen
eine statue und all das findet sich auch
bei google street view wenn wir uns hier
umschauen sehen wir die bögen wir sehen
diese prometheus statue wir können also
mit definitiver sicherheit sagen das
video ist in tschernobyl aufgenommen
worden aber ist das video auch aktuell
ziemlich sicher auf älteren fotos sind
diese bögen hier knallrot gestrichen und
auf aktuellen fotos oder videos sind die
jeweils rot weiß und woher weiß ich dass
die aktuell rot weiß sind es gibt ein
anderes video in der russischen
nachrichtenagentur
wo das genau so zu sehen ist und auch
das wetter stimmt überein das video ist
ja angeblich am 24 februar aufgenommen
worden man sieht hier so ein bisschen
graue wolken bedeckte himmel und genau
so war das wetter auch in privat am 24
februar
auch diese panzer typen die man hier
sieht die werden von der russischen
armee genutzt auf der front dass ein
panzers den wir hier sehen ist eine v
förmige weiße markierung zu erkennen
auch das könnte ein hinweis darauf sein
dass russische streitkräfte sind die
haben nämlich auf ihren fahrzeugen durch
buchstaben als improvisierte kennung
gemalt am ende spricht so vieles dafür
dass dieses video wirklich in
tschernobyl am 24 februar aufgenommen
wurde dass das russische panzer sind das
andere erklärung eigentlich nicht
plausibel sind
dieses video hier dagegen dass es fake
angeblich ist hier die explosion einer
vakuum bombe in der ukraine zu sehen
aber das video ist jahre alt das wird
deutlich wenn man einen screenshot aus
diesem video in eine bilder
rückwärtssuche einfügt
man kann endlich in suchmaschinen ein
foto hochladen hier mache ich das mal in
der russischen suchmaschine yandex
kommen und dann bekommt man webseiten
angezeigt die genau dieses bild oder
video auch enthalten und hier sieht man
die aufnahmen sind wahrscheinlich aus
syrien auf jeden fall aber gab es die
schon im jahr 2019
das waren jetzt zwei beispiele wie man
solche bilder und videos verifizieren
kann mit google maps mit street view mit
der bilder rückwärtssuche mit
verschiedenen suchmaschinen und das ist
etwas das kann auch jeder zu hause
machen